- Welcome back!
All right, we are celebrating
Pasta Week all week long,
that's why we call it Pasta Week.
And what better way to pay
homage to the humble noodle
than a cookbook club pick
with my culinary partner in crime?
Today's pick comes from
the great Hetty McKinnon
and my culinary partner in crime
is the one and only Chef Pilar Valdes!
(audience applauds)
- Hi everyone.
So today what we're doing
is a spicy Sesame Tantanmen Ramen
from Hetty McKinnon's
"To Asia, With Love."
I love that cookbook.
All the recipes in this
book, "To Asia, With Love"
are actually vegetarian.
The recipe we're making
today is actually vegan.
So what you have there
is some Sesame oil with
some ginger and garlic
that's been sauteing,
and then we're gonna throw
in our crumbled, firm tofu
into that mixture,
and it just smells so good.
So we've mixed everything in,
and then Drew, to your side,
you're gonna have mirin,
which is a Japanese
rice wine, cooking wine,
and then we're gonna do a
little bit of tamari, as well,
and then we're gonna see
throw in the miso paste also.
- I love miso paste.
- [Pilar] So Drew, as soon
as you have that mixed in
really nicely,
- [Drew] Okay.
- Nice and crumbled,
you're just gonna let it go
actually, and stop mixing it.
And what that's gonna do
is basically develop
this nice, crispy crust
on the tofu as it cooks.
So while that's cooking, I'm at a seven,
we're gonna make the sauce,
or the broth, basically.
So in the bowl,
we're gonna whisk up a little,
in the bowl you have some tahini,
so we're gonna put a little
bit more of the tamari,
and that's gonna give you
again, that deep savoriness.
Lovely.
And then, to a break up a
little bit of the creaminess,
you're gonna have a little
bit of the rice wine vinegar
in that bowl.
Oh, that's starting to look really nice.
And then we have some chili oil.
So as soon as you're all mixed in, Drew,
we're gonna walk over to
the big pot over here,
and in this pot we have
some vegetable stock
and some soy milk.
So that's, again, the creaminess,
you're just building that in.
If you don't wanna do soy milk,
you can absolutely substitute
for any of your favorite
nut milks, basically.
And you're gonna whisk that in, Drew.
I'm gonna ch check my, ooh,
so you can see,
I'm getting all this texture,
you have a little bit of crispy, crunchy,
and then the softness too,
and that's exactly where you want it.
All right, I'm gonna pop that off.
And then, Drew,
I think we're ready to
assemble our ramen bowl.
- [Drew] Great.
- All right, so what Hetty says
is basically cook your
favorite ramen noodle,
according to the package instructions,
and then in the last 30 seconds,
into the water, throw your vegetable.
So here we have some leafy greens
and some bean sprouts,
so you really just wanna
shock the raw off of it,
but you still want it
to be crunchy.
- I love it.
- Nice and fresh, so shall we assemble?
- Yes, please.
- Yes, let's do it.
All right, so you have
your cooked ramen noodles.
- Cooked.
- A little bit of greens.
I know you love your
beans sprouts too, right?
- I love beans sprouts.
I love crunch.
I need texture.
- And then we've got
some, speaking of texture,
some sweet corn, as well.
- I love that touch.
- So that's gonna be a
real nice pop of freshness,
'cause she to keep the kernels raw.
And then your tofu, lest we forget,
lest we forget.
(audience applauds)
So I'm pouring my nice broth over here,
treating myself to something real special.
And then we got your garnish.
We got some Sesame seeds,
toasted Sesame seeds,
a little bit of scallion.
- Is this a Szechuan chili crisp?
- And then it's more
chili crisp, basically.
We did say it was gonna be hot.
And there you have it.
It's Hetty McKinnon's Spicy
Sesame Tantanmen Ramen.
- Love it, it's so beautiful.
(audience applauds)
- [Both] Cheers!
- Oh, Pilar, I love you so much.
Thank you for bringing this to the table.
(audience applauds)
- Mmm!
- Mmm.
Oh my God, Pilar.
- That is so good.
- It just made me weak in the knees.
- That is so, so good.
- Like a man!
- I need to go in.
- A man hasn't made me weak in the knees
(Pilar laughs)
like this ramen has.
I need to date this ramen.
- Thank you, Hetty.
(Pilar laughs)
You can pick up a copy of
our recommended cookbook
or get the full recipe at the website,
TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com.
- And thank you, Pilar,
for bringing this pick to the week.
And we be right back.
(upbeat music)